[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are going to be talking
about girl approved we're gonna be
talking about adding new senses to
humanity increasing our perception
increasing the scientific method we have
so much to unpack with our guests today
Heidi tree Stangl meyer thank you so
much for coming what you doing so oh it
was really all that was real I didn't
make that up yeah everything that you
discuss is so important and we are about
to unpack that okay and as much detail
as we can in our super short episodes
which are still kind of long but we'll
try and get as much of it done as we can
I'm here alright so we got 12 years as
the founder of girl approved yes yes wow
that's quite a while now so now this has
been a 12 year experiment that you are
running
yes tell us about this experiment they
do the experiment well I think it's you
know to understand the motive of it we
had to go back to when I was at
Princeton and I was working on my
doctorate and computer science
well actually was in quantum physics and
AI looking at the intersection of them
and that's when I started to wonder if I
was picking up on different information
than some of the men in the department
because even though they were all super
smart there was certain like theorems
there's really hard to solve that were
kind of easy for me and so I kept having
these things where I'm like hmm I think
I know more or I could see them so
problems that I knew weren't correct and
they would be unintended consequences so
I I started to wonder that if being
female I was picking up on different
patterns in nature than my male peers
and that became really a motivation for
me because I realized that this
information could solve hard problems or
even prevent many
intended consequences and it could be
applicable and to design and so so
anyway the my experiment was the first
time ever that girls mobilised to
explore what they were naturally capable
of cognitively and creatively
independent of what was a sign for men
and that was sort of the motive so it
wasn't really like I wasn't looking at
man saying hey you have fifty titles and
you're not getting paid more I was like
[ __ ] I really think that there's
something fundamental missing from
science forecasting design that that I
can pick up on and if we capture that
maybe we'll do a better job here in
culture and medicine in any other field
so that was motivation for my experiment
and we have this really awesome graphic
that to show as well on our on our
stream and it's the first kind of
graphic that you sent me as well can we
throw it up in studio as well no it's
all good yeah yeah and so in you know
here you see that it's like these like a
chess board and you have men man made
and then woman girl approved boys help
has arrived and after 5,000 years of
letting men play master creator there's
this sort of unleashing and unlocking of
this full potential of women and you use
the word delight and I love that word
well if you already see here it's like
after 5,000 years of letting men play
master creator helping arrive boys which
is so what we need is help I mean the
foundation from genetics to quantum
physics without some hard problems that
have AI there's hard problems out there
that we need to crack and what is Ashley
was very important this even the design
of this is
I didn't I did a representation of the
female and what was her move it wasn't
just any old woman it was the chess
player actually I you know the Queen has
a very powerful role she can go anywhere
she pleases that's why I chose us but
it's important because it represents the
symbology of what is you know what are
the rules that govern her behavior on
the game of life so basically what's
very very important is I'm not saying
men's suck this is nothing subjective
we're not getting paid if we're bringing
to the table is exactly what has driven
progress from the beginning of time
which is better tool you know
advancements to science advancements to
knowledge better metrics better models
yes and so I'm not a female group
talking about how much money I bring me
I'm not talking subjectively or begley
I'm saying look you guys for 5000 years
have presented the first set of
engineering and economic tools using
your instrument your man Nate and they
got us an amazing step forward but we
need a little something new not because
we need something new because they're
stuck is five seconds bug and so anyway
that's sort of just set the tone before
I share the work and we have this slide
that's coming up as well that explains
the senses that will pull it up but the
slide that explains sense is just
hearing sight touched a steel etc and
that there is something else past that
that we're not really exploring and some
of those that we talked about prior to
this we're meaning meaningful engagement
another one being cause-and-effect
understanding how people have the
feelings that they have and why they
have them what variables are going on
for that and then I had the heads of the
road was creativity as well was another
one I really thought that these were
kind of like key principles to unlock in
the human spirit
so what I want to say and then I'm gonna
explain that but before we go on it says
here new rule everyone wins
yeah so
I just want to set the tone that even
though it was females that did this work
our entire motive was can we help
humanity better you know can we do a
better job at cultural design you know
can and medicine improve you know can
industrial design improve can we predict
and understand our true needs better can
we deal something about mental illness
so it's like everyone wins this is not a
man versus women thing oh so so what you
brought important to reiterate huge yeah
this is everyone wins this is not man
versus woman whatsoever no this is
actually unlocking the full potential of
humanity by figuring out that there is
so much delight within the child of both
a girl as well as a boy and we kind of
squashed that by our economic and
political system well you actually
brought up an interesting point is why
did I say girl approved so the the
experiment was really about after like
all from a young age and not you know
women are brought up to study the
philosophical spiritual scientific
ontological all of these belief systems
and methods and mathematics is all
awesome
but they've all pretty much come from
the male instrument and so what I
started to realize that I didn't want to
just know what it was to be a mature
woman who's mastered all of that was
there something as a female as a girl
born with it was I born with the
capacity to contribute across that that
had never really been explored that's
why I didn't say woman approved yeah
yeah I wanted to discover so something I
was born with not Todd yeah and so but
you get to what's the experiment that's
really what you're getting at and the
experiment was that you know if you look
to the history of time the big question
is who have we trusted for the knowledge
that we need to be all we can be whether
it's personally or collectively or that
which governs you know our politics you
know our culture and if you look
throughout time it was we had
either the artistic spiritual men for a
long long time and then with the
Scientific Revolution the does the
scientist so there was a real changing
of the guards between the artistic where
I might call the more feminine men you
know the spiritual artistic the poet you
know the men move from within is
primarily what was honored the most in
terms of visionary you know and who we
looked up to for thoughts but no one's
kind of like telescopes and microscopes
and that well it's like the poets and
then who you know who did the kings
higher so we really had a great regard
for the beliefs of those more like
spiritual and inward and now or moved
more in the Renaissance exactly so even
so I would have said that you one might
even call that the more feminine but if
you look at the inward day that's what
we look to and then with the scientific
method there was a using shift and
that's when the you know the men came
along and said okay well what if any of
these like you know the some guru was
crazy neat you know it these were people
with special skills so the point of
science was sort of to unionize truth
and say okay what can we all know so
that no man would be under some
oppression some sort of crazy guru dude
or some religious system that shut down
the truth so really they're trying to
unionize human knowledge and the
advancement not that so it was a good
thing definitely but I'm so but
restricted to the five senses or before
we get that they could only give math to
the five senses but it was still the
spiritual man versus the sight more like
say metric menses there was one side as
like if you can't measure it if we can't
speak if you can't you know it doesn't
exist all they came about what can we
measure and what can we test empirically
and that was really part of the inside
moved or outside senses that was really
what it was about and so it was really a
division between what part of the human
experience do we trust or not
and so basically if you couldn't measure
it if you couldn't give it a mathematics
it didn't exist and that's really what
the spiritual men the artists couldn't
do even though they were governed by
something so they're seeing this whole
new math this whole new system of
modeling this whole new system of
metrics well that was just worthless
objective for the internal for
experience as well as the greens have
blend that exactly the man threw that
out they didn't know how to do with it
so they threw it out but you have to
realize is that I think it was retained
also through environments like Buddhism
and through the practice of meditation
like specially I'm gonna update a empty
it was actually retained through other
print like Freemasonry in all of this
alchemist if you look at the founding
fathers they actually were personally
governed by the belief alka mystic
beliefs those were inward practices and
so those were highly what you call
enlightened men but there became a
problem so it was good intention but we
met we did we hadn't talked about women
at that point the men were like coming
out of the age of era they didn't
consider the female a trustworthy
instrument because she was so given to
emotion and intuition so when they came
up with what can we give science
language metrics to they decided to I
consider the male instrument idealized
so what they did was they didn't just
dismiss the poetic men they didn't
include the women because we were
considered too driven by these fleets of
intuition so all's we really really
really knew is when they unionized men
what can they all give language to you
can't say anything
so that was an untested assumption that
the women's intuition or the women would
like dirty up the data we were like a
really good like a like an inaccurate
instrument not augment the data now get
better which is what word wets word why
do shift into but remember there was a
lot of people that believed in the
inward world and we're still back at
back today they just couldn't give it a
language of math on
they couldn't operationalize it they
couldn't explain it scientifically so
anyway so you have to realize is that
suddenly we have this viewpoint and that
viewpoint is all based on this is where
the ninety-six comes in what you can
describe with the outside world the part
of the mind they could model is known
today it's only like three to four
percent and what the brains really
picking up on on how it really models
things but they could only model four
percent of the world the physical part
that's all they could describe is the
physical dynamics and that's only four
percent but what happened was now they
have this you know here's our new laws
this 4 percent box of what we know and
it wasn't just that we all of a sudden
everything had to comply to that so
education had to be defined through that
health so instead of this whole global
experience are capable of everything
that became legitimate trustworthy
respectable modern science had to comply
even anything we explain one explained
to that four percent and that became a
real reductionism on understanding
living experiences and so what's super
important is they want to make sure that
just to say because right right here
this is somewhere where I've kind of
like pushed back on you a little bit
although I agree with you in many ways
I'm still unsure if it's like ninety
nine percent or 1 percent or sixty eight
percent and you know whatever 32 percent
because I quite sold on the exact
percentages but I'm happy that you found
a numbered system I think makes it makes
sense these are numbers of people speak
about we only could model the exterior
senses only you know the outside senses
only describe 3ish percent of what the
brain is picking up on they don't really
know I mean that comes from neuroscience
they know that if you describe what
you're seeing right here right now
time-space of this you know this one you
only see a small fraction of it yeah
there's a whole lot of shakin
microbial you'd know they don't know
what's going on in the brain that only
described a little bit of hardening flow
that's going from your visual cortex
into your thalamus right now that's
that's that's giving you the idea of
where you are and what you're perceiving
not actually it's six times more
information is going from the brain in
then then from outside into the brain so
yes there's but see these perception I
just let's just say it's a tiny bit
compared to the other yeah and that's
that's kind of where I was just going
okay but I just sort of named it now it
turned out that if you want to look at
the world and where that's made up of
some of it's made up a matcher and the
rest of the unified field so you're
talking about what proportion is matter
versus energy that's kind of in the 4%
also so it seems to be that there seemed
to be this number link between matter
describing the world inserting the
physical and the outside senses
yeah like stars planets star dust is
about like four percent and then you
have dark energy and dark matter that's
96 percent yeah it's very interesting
that nature proper is made up of soar
therefore into something else
you know and then the mind is the same
there seemed to be some relation so
that's what I got the 96 however what's
super awesome other slides to get
through to so they just wanted yam is
the what do you you have to understand
that what they couldn't explain and what
we're up to today is at the moment you
have a thinking creature a conscious
person their science falls flat the
moment you're thinking you're changing
the particles so this four percent this
it's trying to explain something trying
to do can I understand the world so I
can make really smart fit choices yeah
yeah the moment you have a thinking
creature it doesn't work so we have to
realize that that's all science gave us
so far we have a lot more to unpack
through and actually a lot of the
beautiful visuals that you've made
through this will further kind of
explain and visually make it easy to
understand your
all right keep it going yeah I kinda
selfish do we need fixed culture again
this is a this is a perspectives like
culture right now I needs the
augmentation of exactly because
eventually if it didn't and then talk
about the computers if you couldn't
model it if all that other stuff they
couldn't they left on the cutting-room
floor it way it didn't end up in the
computer so the more that everything got
automated I mean if you were an
enlightened person it didn't matter but
what happened is more and more education
everything had to fit into these
automated mechanized system that's when
we became a very dangerous culture
because what was missing was science
started to be missing an engineering in
economics and in medicine and then got
coded into that the SAT scores
everything started to have to reflect it
was like a dated contagion I love this
one because this is basically saying
that think about all of the incredible
ideas that have not been born yet
because this product label these ideas
haven't come into our world yet right
and so what you're trying to get at is
that you can say great job so far and
you know what if you're looking at
mechanistically
you know models of engineering where
they gave us great things bridges
infrastructures incredible yes and even
in medicine they gave us a structure but
yet somehow is the mental that some
other diseases are escalating but why
cuz it's not the full story you know so
it's not that we got you have to they ma
the engineers for what their it was a
beginning you know the nonliving world
to understand that but even a gun okay a
gun is they're optimizing how fast it
shoots but if we don't understand the
human mind that's we have to go we're
not gonna get you know you have to
understand that if we want to end gun
violence you know because it starts it
starts right here exactly you can't
understand where we are in the world
with physical things only with non
conscious beings a point exactly
Sud guru was talking to David Eagleman
about who we hosted on Friday when he
said that I love science they've done a
great job but I wish scientists would
meditate and that speaks so much truth
to me about that Katie is awesome but
that doesn't give you a universal model
to step in the direction right it was
saying that okay get some data out here
but that's such a little bit it's a good
start we need that but unless we
understand it's like it said what's
going on the inner mind you won't
understand what any is how this affects
us you know you won't so what we're
seeing is this is the frontier yeah the
Sony anywhere it is the frontier and
where does frontier yeah exactly
oh here's a disc or eclaim er this
flamer is that
no I'm you're talking like oh who is
this chick and she's talking this big
stuff okay I want to say that everything
I learned I learned by doing empirical
tests in live culture working with the
biggest brands and nice just right here
all of these so this is not I'm not like
the other people out there and LM
tweaking at something when we show this
is work done with 15-under girls from
around the world showing that we have an
intellectual creative untapped capacity
yes that if formalized and used to
augment engineering and economics in
science that it would have a fundamental
positive impact not just on females and
humanity but the bottom line of business
is so by money billions dollars and new
revenues made and 2 billion again in bad
investments prevented and that's across
all these different brands a way we show
that with you could talk a for present
world view might give you the answer a
the likelihood of a being wrong is 96%
like this is why if you look at venture
capital today they don't understand the
human experience so the likelihood
they'll just get
just sending a little you know bomb out
there and see what happened in the rest
of the 96% Brahe so what in order for us
to get more accurate to understand will
this thing either create harm and
humanity does it does it actually meet a
desire that's left unspoken is there
frustration what's going on in that 96
they don't understand how what they
create really will will relate to us but
yet if you go to the mechanical things
you understand you know how to make
motors you understand cause and effect
you understand forces you understand the
laws that govern these physical things
you were really good in medicine when it
comes to bones and we can glue them back
together but look at all the diseases
that are coming up the mental diseases
all of these it like informational
diseases and viruses that's all
information faced and it doesn't can't
be answered by gluing bones back we
can't we do something else about this
ethereal human experience yeah needs to
be discussed and figured out over time
and that has to do with this meaning
this cause and effect this creative
potential within us that is kind of
being again just pressed down on by that
current economic like where we're
actually you're saying is that we are
now instead of using what we know about
science to expand and enable the full
potential of humanity alright the more
everything's run by algorithm the more
that algorithm doesn't have this data in
it the more humans are normalizing a
Janell adapting reducing ourselves down
do I match the four to the denial of our
own you know capacity so anyway there it
is science was built on the exterior
yeah better that's all good it got is
four percent that's a great start guys
but this is the frontier the inside
senses so not a good side
that's it but see and everybody's still
it's so funny because when they're
talking about that concept of
singularity it's acting like we're
tapped out on learning it doesn't
account for the fact that we've been
dealer nning we've been opressing
learning
who's we that's what I you know I just
want to chime in here as you're talking
about fit this is a good question Ron
who's the we that is oppressing well
there's a dark villain among us I'm not
in denial of this and you talked about
this dawning of a new era where we're
going to understand go beyond our
physical 3d reality and dip into deeper
dimensions but we need to understand
there is something among us that does
not want us to go here it's been keeping
us in this 3d realm for the longest of
time and they're scared shitless right
now they don't want this conversation
happening
they don't want young people listening
to this and scratching their heads and
saying wow this makes sense how come my
mum and dad don't talk like this so we
need to be very careful but I'm stoked
about this conversation and about what
you just said who do you think is doing
out of all seven half billion people or
even a force outside of Earth outside of
these dimensions what do you think is
causing the sort of oppression that is
occurring of this creativity of these
senses well so it's
it would there's a couple ways to look
at this is they're bad people you know
or is there so one we could look at it
mathematically you're like okay awesome
you're an instrument with the boy part
I'm an interested meet with the Carol
part what's your instrument in the role
we know what it is physically what men
and women bring to the table for
creation but wasn't about metaphysically
metaphysically informational II so you
clip just look at it to say okay uh
apparently like let's say objective
level is that the map that we've created
so far just simply left ninety-six
percent on the cutting room floor
and they never thought they could model
it it was like that's just the unknown
the unknowable that's what they labeled
it and then there's except we can't know
so it was more of like an accident a
human you could this is one narrative
you could just say like perfectly well
intended guy and then for years you woke
up oh that's just unknowable don't go
there who goes there
I mean even the women today oh that's
just you sweetie feeling that way you're
like oh yeah that's all just squelch
that so you could say okay fine we ended
up with this little lens the outward
lens and anything we could see there was
real and the rest was unknowable
anyway genocide was unknowable yeah and
then that keeps going for years and then
it's judged and what we actually show it
starts draining out of the methods then
it drained if it's not in the methods
its draining all the things we create
with the methods and then we're
interacting with it you know and then it
drains it it's like the business model
of social media is the attention economy
rather than actually making fruitful
connections between people and making
humanity better in many ways we are on
an algorithm of extinction so that would
be one way that's just an objective way
because well because we weren't involved
but again is it these people are not
debts and then if you look at the
genetics like how many years have been
passed along that these things aren't
real and lots of years exactly turning
inward not understanding the inside
census so that's all coming
along with you all that due to
epigenetic that's one way to look at it
however there's some other weird [ __ ]
because I've already cracked these codes
and I went on a tour of scientists from
all around the world we actually said
this interestingly over here we said the
scientific method is incomplete I like
that way that we described it that I
wasn't what to say it was broken
it wasn't yeah we we just we're gonna
it's incomplete there's more to complete
it over time and let's keep adding to it
with this inside senses that you're
describing right and I mean again you
could say give it as great intention but
I wanted to add one thing when we
discovered this new extension to science
it started to head to a lot of the
ancient spiritual principles so we we
went to get support in to peer review
from scientists all around the world
very famous multiple Nobel laureate but
we also went to people like the
scientists at work with the Dalai Lama
monks at the Vatican because it started
to observe the a Kabbalistic rabbis you
know we did the whole the devout show
but all of that because it started to
mimic ancient doctrine yeah and I'll
tell you what's super interesting is
that so we were more enlightened before
we understood more of the inside senses
before but yes well that's really at the
end of the day all the the universal
doctrines are trying to tell you that
the trying to give you a map you know
the their best effort of trying to tell
you a mechanics give you an explanation
of the inner forces and the inner
knowledge they and how important it is
but they did it in a very ornamental way
but I will want to add on to that all of
these spiritual classic principles have
mythology's parts of their narrative
about women having certain information
and losing that information it's like
what Adam and Eve who spoke to the tree
of knowledge who is talking to Eve so
they have all had this universal
narrative of women knowing something and
that knowledge getting lost and falling
into a dark period where we don't know
that which will evolve us that
fit in that which will harm us that is
universal and in some ways what we
defined in the inner mind is the
directional information to say this is
where evolution is and these are the
things that are good or bad so I ask
myself why universally did win and
forego what they knew and meant to give
that all to men and I will even say that
if you look at the ancient the Knights
Grail seeking the Holy Grail that's all
about looking for the lost information
of evolution longevity life the Grail a
lot you know and what was the symbol
that they sought it was that symbol was
basically that the shape of the vagina
they were see that's always something to
do with the woman this again is
witnessed across multiple cultures so
there is something that went down and
nobody could tell me what was it like
some sort of like metaphysical like
mimetic flu and we went you got one
group got over air again and one went
too small I don't know but it's
something this is a universal so it was
very interesting because many of these
people said in high spiritual people
that were really and they like oh the
world was waiting
a lot of Kabbalistic rabbis the we've
been waiting for this it's predicted
yeah we would recover knowledge yeah it
totally feels like it is coming into
society it feels really good actually
it was the first time that I was judging
the first robotics tournament when there
was a group of girls that won the
inspire award which is the biggest award
and it felt so good seeing just a group
of girls that were feeling actualized
doing something that was completely
different than what culture cultural
norms are like but we have to also
differentiate from a woman participating
in the 4% science and kicking but that's
fine
from expand a new frontier of science
yes
and using the tools in that to both
correct and expand and that's really
what I'm so like annoyed with the
Silicon Valley today we don't know these
tools yet though no we do right well
know that well we don't know how to
we're trying to figure out how to
measure meaning and measure cause and
effect and creativity in these but
that's what we just got verga nurse
because we didn't just meet the
spiritual people we met scient linguist
logicians epigenetics we even met the
Stephen Hawkins lab and presented our
new science so I want to say that how do
you say it wasn't known the book that's
what we discovered so we did discover
the math the language society needed a
language men could never master they
thought it was beyond words they of the
inner mind so we found the language of
math is all hidden in there this is what
we this is why we're it said new tools
so we can take science and add this data
impure and we can take engineering and
extend it so it's more you know cultural
new form of cultural engineering we can
expand our understanding biology but it
wasn't known and we just got to figure
out what those intelligence is those
models metrics equations oh we did it
already
yeah we're donating back so it's not
like we have to that was our 12 year
experiment I just thought you know this
is what I asked you before but then like
what are those equations well first of
all God okay
I'd only spit it out I'm saying okay so
remember when they talk about non
time-space it's a time-space is
artificial mm-hmm it's not something I
can explain really really quickly
but let's just you come all the people
you're interviewing are always talking
about time-space isn't real like in
holographic universe you speak to those
people I know you do don't you
yes yeah okay well would I time-space is
like one picture of the world right here
right now and that's all that damn well
matters okay that's the knowledge of the
science but now they know
epigenetically shits been building up in
our DNA and they also know that somehow
we're connected to other things so
that's what I'm just saying is a whole
bunch of other information that we need
to understand what it might create like
just like we crave food and also you
need some like protein in this stuff
we've blocked there is things about what
hurts us and what what's good for us so
you your skin has an algorithm it's like
I'm gonna put it over fire it burns that
you came with that algorithm did you not
okay
well the inner minds got lots of
important algorithms and there are
different things that are harmful like
is something burned your skin or taste
bad it's because your body's rejecting
it it's giving you data there's an
algorithm to protect you so that you're
making great choices
another thing algorithms you have is
things that you're craving I'm craving
water that's an allegory that stats
touch base that's and that's partially
an outside sense as well fire and the
hand touch it's at your pain and your
yeah but then there's things that are
not the exterior senses which is what
you're indicating to hear properties and
so basically what I'm just trying to
unpack is you know you know you did the
12 years like we got just you know I'm
just curious what are then the math the
models the intelligence they're gonna
tell you there's a whole lot of
information what is really important to
understand is that anything we interact
with in the world it picks up crap so
you breathe in some oxygen and we got to
get the rid of the carbon
pick up a little carbon okay you eat
some food to take a dump
interaction to drink you think of this
song you need and some is not good for
you and we have algorithms in place okay
what if you'd really bad fish
well you then you have the run algorithm
get rid of that [ __ ] or the puke
algorithm but what we actually show is
that the part of our brain that were
using has
it is only the frontal lobes we've
actually shut down the algorithms for us
to understand what is actually true or
not
so even information in the out so the
outer mind will think something's true
if it's repeated it's only mechanical so
all they have to do is repeat something
good enough it does not discern what is
true our faults what is good for your
back
so simply repetition creates truth in
the frontal lobes so one of the things
in the back brain we're shutting down is
the same kind of algorithms that we have
for other interactions that are gonna
tell you if we need to get rid of this
thing or not we've lost access to the
correction mechanism so that's one of it
is very important it's going to tell you
that just as though something burns or
hurt or not in something about some
thing that you're interacting with
environment is actually nutritious or
not you know there's a whole bunch of
stuff so it's really important time for
an example because you made the fish
example bad fish and you got puke or
boob algorithm in this case it would be
maybe an s something regarding energy
you intake some sort of energy from
someone else as a human being and you
kind of makes you feel a certain way and
then you just have to have that part of
your algorithms and your brain activated
in order to know whether or not that
means you feel happy sad or what emotion
and then maybe what to do with that
information well I think the best is to
wow I can't believe that was what 15
minutes yeah we're it we're already in
the forty I just so we're all ready
we're all no I'm just saying I can't
believe that was already forty minutes
it's absolutely nuts and I knew this
would happen when we first started
talking but you know that's just the way
that the life is is that we just we're
world were that we only have this is a
15 to 15 minute timer let's produce him
let's produce her own show let's do
something every week yeah yeah let's
explore like what that what stuff like
this would look like so okay so we we
have a lot of work to do to make this
very relatable for the
masses and whatever that has to learn
yeah oh yeah yeah ton of case studies
yeah yeah yeah you you do you you've
made a really great incredible
presentation and also just your last 12
years of understanding this and all that
stuff so I think what we should do I
think for this episode at least let's do
our best to get through as much of of
what we're like of these highlights as
possible I yeah so we're so and then
we'll and then we'll come to more of
what we were just talking about but so
okay so we've been told our whole life
feelings aren't fact all right so we all
have instances where we're in a
situation doesn't feel right you know or
for example like it just think of modern
advertising like if your lips don't look
this way
you're not like attractive well now that
to my belief system heard that enough
now your entire sense of your own
sexuality is gonna be around to
manufactured imprint of your lips at
that point it doesn't even matter but if
you had something deeper that was just
connected it makes us a victim it makes
us malleable to these nasty patterns
that can control us and we've lost that
recovery we've lost the ability to self
intercept okay so when you're young you
get conditioned and when we actually end
up showing where meditation is quiet the
brain what we end up showing this is
inside information is trying to tell us
all sorts of important stuff oh here's
another good example of what I was
mentioning earlier is that you're the
ninety six to four it this is this is
split 50-50 do you know what I mean so
it there just needs to be I guess a
little bit cohesion in the sense of like
what percentage do we actually
objectively understand is really this
outside senses and what percentage is
inside senses and then it would be
really important to maybe have a list
here as well if outside senses have
these five relatable images what would
be the five or three relatable images of
the inside senses meaning creativity
cause-and-effect what would those look
like and how could they relatable
attention it's a lot tension like forces
drives tension
those desires these are funny yeah we
wrote them here then it would be easier
for people to understand as well and
this is kind of where I'd love to we'll
talk about guns guns I mean here we
don't underst
you know what wouldn't you bring to the
gun if you're a bigger if you've just
been abused and you show up with the gun
if science is trying to describe what
the hell is really happening what what's
the reality of this that's a different
reality if you have somebody who's been
abused their whole life in front of the
gun then if you have somebody who's
really passive like me I mean you could
just grab the the meaning of the gun for
me I could just use it to pound avocados
that's as useful as it is for me
so meanie has to understand what the
state of the inner mind yeah so one of
the things is that the other thing is
that so there's universal truths that
means that there are forces there thrive
there are facts
there is oldest information that we the
ability to use that part of our mind to
document why so that we can do what
science wants predict behaviors make
design cultures diagnose problems
this is very useful [ __ ] and we've been
we need to recover that yep and it's not
just the new so that becomes new day
origins exactly and so your mind is the
new frontier it is and that's what I'm
saying we converted into data and this
is just a little bit of me back at
Princeton but it's how I learned that
and we kind of went through that and I
want to make it clear here this is
another one of those kind of like areas
that I think is really important to
address for for audience that might be
feeling a little bit like you know like
mm I don't really resonate with this and
let me explain a kind of like my take on
how I think we can all resonate with
this better it's not that a hundred
percent of all men think that that the
that that think that what is being
described here regarding of regarding
maybe feeling or senses that are
internal they don't think that it's
irrational weird and just opinion it's
not a hundred percent of men that
that way it's a minority of men that
feel that way I got it sure I'm stopping
you on this one what does this say it's
a science and objective reality okay we
have no framework of understanding the
universal pattern it's not about what
any man said because talk to any good
guy of Wall Street he knows he trusts
his Institute his intuition yeah I'm
talking about what can we model and all
agree on exactly about happening but how
do we describe nature were part of
nature we're part of living system this
can be misleading for a guy to look at
well I say that oh [ __ ] I'm being
categorized as a rash I'm being cat I'm
I'm being categorized as somebody that
thinks that women are irrational and
weird and this is just ideas that we are
not saying that a hundred percent of men
think this way we are saying that a
small percentage of people think just
that way but then there's all this
beautiful gray area that exists which is
what happens inside of the census of
these expanding the scientific method
and if we were to figure out how to
expand the scientific method and figure
out how to add the new sort of girl
approved ideologies of the scientific
method into our crisis now what you're
missing this is really useful because
what I'm talking about here is why did I
get an all-girls scientific peer review
group because if I could show that girls
could sense patterns that that were
universal and had never been documented
and there was enough girls we became
statistically relevant yeah this is what
I'm talking about that's what could
never happen they never had a way to
explain the inner mind that was
measurable repeatable duplicatable or
statistically relevant so even when
people have like all the spiritual
people maybe they have a sense they're
still an anomaly there's still an
outlier and so it's actually what we
call outliers truth go to the next one
for a second yep what did we do the
point so where the menus there are big
data hack where they modeled based on
what they could sense out heard we
actually started to document what we
felt from inside
yo to realize that it was as universal
like if what I mean by universal I say
hey what do you see right there you see
it's a fuzzy bunny oh well we could feel
things that were and everybody saw a
fuzzy bunny then you can go
statistically it's been peer reviewed
it's a funny fuzzy bunny but what I'm
saying with the same thing there's
information inside of us that could
extend our understanding of what's
happening here yes even what's happening
with us and so it's also very hubristic
for people to just think that oh it's
just scientific method that's it
it's just overly self-confident it's not
actually enabling us to realize that oh
my god this whole essence of tuning in
word and senses that are inside its just
have so much value to add to the
scientist but ok but also there's great
philosophers like Amano convict consign
Hegel all of them were at war with the
scientists I'm not the only one they
just couldn't prove it look at this
beautiful people the scientists have
been at work for a long time ok menu
right around synapse but guess what we
had they don't unite around religion and
we have so many wars because of that but
they will steal this unite around
science so not having a language of the
inners actually you know part of war
today so this is all that I said it's
like just taking just as so men did they
went had all these experiments saying
what can we all agree on when we came
language and now to when they gave
science and modern engineering and
modern economic awesome but they just
left [ __ ] on the cutting room floor
their hubris was forgetting all
spirituality and dismissing it well
actually they didn't they just said it
was opt-in but the problem came were
every part of cultural design and
understanding humanity had to comply
with a very little lens that little
Lance became codified notre I'd the
compliance soon we served the 4% so that
was what flipped instead of that 4%
being part of the information we started
to serve it so humans became the slave
and the 4% became the master
and unless we start correcting that we
will let it's the reversal of the power
we gave the power to the number not the
power to the human technology the human
mind the human is the untapped potential
and the singularity acts like we're
tapped out and we're trying to say we've
only just begun yeah thank you oh yeah
that's a great way to to cut the end of
of what we were just talking about Heidi
holy crap what is the new language what
is the new math the new metrics the new
models new forces new dimensions I'm
super excited I was envisioning this
sort of transitionary period where we're
no longer the slave to just the
scientific method and it's in its in its
principles for just the last 500 or so
years and not just the slave to the
external senses but rather like more and
more people are starting to integrate
the new senses the internal senses all
of these new languages and math into an
augment the scientific method it's it's
gonna be such an interesting ride going
into the future we have so much more
creative potential at the I mean of
course really a little taste but what we
really show is that there is such a it's
not us versus nature and that's what
Darwin got that all wrong it shows
there's a link between our biological
evolution and what we create we are
nature is our friend
it's one big co-creation in the
evolutionary process but we have we have
taken our hands off that steering wheel
we're born with the capacity to create
and evolve our own Fitness individually
and collectively and the sad part is
instead of expanding we're fitting into
smaller and smaller grids an AI and
we'll perma-seal the [ __ ] out of human
potential and we will trap us in a very
downward there's no correction mechanism
that's the biggest thing unless we open
up that frontier we're going to live
the incomplete knowledge tell us that's
all there is we need to open that up to
correct ourselves that's the key so our
ability to drive our own evolution our
ability it's called information healing
to correct many of the physical
illnesses this gets to the root of
information it's all day DNA it's all
information and our thoughts are driving
our in art our DNA and if they are being
lost confused corrupted project it is a
corruption we are now mastering our own
extinction and it's nobody yeah
mastering our extinctions that we there
are people acquiescing yes of course
there are people that are not aware of
what's happening but okay bye I guess I
say we cuz I'm not trying to point
fingers bad data is our enemy and let no
he know anybody tell you that they have
any freaking idea of what smart is
because to understand smart you have
testers are the entirety of the mind and
they did not and if they and it is
dangerous it is a dangerous promise of
singularity Peter whatever Demetrius you
listen up to demand us Dementor recurse
well those guys need to listen the hell
up and we need to have a talk these
listening how did you have any children
sewed a dress no shame mmm so the way
that you were talking especially in the
last like minute or so here about the
we're not careful about what we're doing
moving forward it makes it a lot more
systems makes us more susceptible to
having a negative next couple of decades
with this sort of exponential
technologies that are around us and I
completely agree with you if we get more
of the humanitarian principles
prioritizing codes codes are all damned
codes getting the codes of exactly what
we're chatting about about these new
languages these new maths of this of the
internal senses and of everything else
working behavior we're gonna succeed we
Oh unbelievable what you can do anything
could be designed to be an object of
human transformation of bliss of delight
we are just we're designing misery into
our world like by choice we we are not
in control of the the power of our will
the control we have over our happiness
you're asking like why are you so happy
because I I'm working with my brain I'm
not working with his dirty data anymore
I liberated myself to be working this is
so important because we had this we were
just talking about this at the beginning
but you used the word delight and
delight is this what was the exact way
that it was described as described as
great pleasure of life and I loved the
idea of boys and girls in their delight
this sort of great pleasure this
overwhelming pleasure you can see
happiness in their soul and whatever
happens with the economic and political
educational machine that does whatever
it does to their minds it's not
maximizing their delight throughout life
and we see a lot of adults today
including myself now as an adult that is
literally looking back and going why are
we squashing the creative potential of
so much of this beauty and girls and
boys
yeah like think of this we have a line
you can feel all of this and first only
this you're allowed to acknowledge
you're probably crazy if you admit the
other that's shrinking because there's
so much error in that system when you're
expanding it out everything is wonder oh
and this is connected this and this is
what we can do and look at how much
you're savoring it's just a chair no
one's not a chair look at this cool
curve and how it fits in my back
we're shutting down the human experience
think of scientists giving language all
of what's locked back there's a language
of describing how we've held things feel
and how they feel to us and what's you
know the nuance and what could be
there's so much then we've locked away
and so it is that we're training
ourselves to die we're dying you think
of it as death is less experienced and
you can see we're because what is think
of entropy a free system the more
entropy higher or enters patterns but
it's also free we don't know where it is
because so many possibility we're we're
actually going the opposite we're
eliminating our own possible ability to
feel to know to create that's tragedy
its tragedy we can start tomorrow
this is trainable skills anybody can
learn to use their brain better that's
not we got this all right brain hurts
last the last couple of questions on the
way out these are some of the questions
that we asked on the show a lot first
question is do you think that do you
think that we're alone in the cosmos oh
[ __ ] well if you actually even
understand epigenetics that those that
live before you are passing on
information you're living in the life
experiences of all for thousands of
years and if you realize that energy is
affecting you I mean I I mean before I
go to alien beams I just think we're
living in the presence of so many beings
that have distilled information and are
there to try to support you whether
they're talking to your genes for
generations or whether they're
interconnected so just that very thought
that I'm not alone in this I love that
you're looking at the lineage of all
hundred billion humans that have lived
and died before us today and we're
totally not alone in that sense all that
informations baked right into who we are
of the language that has been spoken all
the art that's been made yeah but let's
keep passing it on do you think we're in
a simulation well I don't like that word
because I think we associate that word
with some dumb sci-fi stuff and then we
get all weird and
visualization but for example if I
thought you look like a murderer that I
saw on TV and I'm in a cafe sitting next
to you I can create a whole scenario in
my head that might as well be live in
present and that if you're not in
command of your own fears the part that
9 to 6 it's a very creative thing back
there and it's imagining also to seeing
them stuff what's the damn different
it's a simulator it's a simulator to
project make better choices but
unchecked and never learned how to
access it is a dangerous one and instead
that's what becomes again a tool to our
destruction so it's it becomes
epigenetically and green yeah oh God
nice cool maladaptive that is supposed
to be involving us we're downward so
yeah everything we're living in a
simulation if we never learn to
understand that the beliefs and the bad
coding that's driving us but the more
you become in command of your own mind
the more you look at your mind you go oh
how the [ __ ] did that stupid thing get
in there fearless Leary correcting the
thing then it's less of a simulation so
it's only a simulation that's right I
don't like the word if we don't taught
how much is going on back there that's
creating what we think is here we don't
scrape back as much as we can throw
those curtains up then we're living when
what is real remember science is to
describe reality and if we don't know
what's back there we don't know what
fake [ __ ] were making up yeah and I
might as well be real so make it
physical when you make it end of the
simulation and then VR what the [ __ ]
that right though it makes it feel so
not every day this is every day
important to everyone that lives
everyone if you want to personally and
for your family for everyone make the
most intelligent decision for now and
for the future we got to pull back
curtains and get through that 4% yeah we
have the boulder of ignorance we remove
the simulation by getting in redounded
that's what science was supposed to give
us didn't it like okay it got a good
start
great guy great
guys not the full story here we go into
the full story yes the full story like
how you make that as relatable as
possible to today into moving forward
although a lot of the conversations
around the virtual realities as well as
life on other planets and and what that
looks like to be simulated is actually
extremely important to increase
someone's awareness to many dimensions
of thinking simultaneously it's
extremely important to be able to dive
into the understanding that if we don't
understand our emotional states and we
don't get that 96% that we're actually
taking a huge backseat in terms of
understanding reality last question is
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
the energy that lives in every human and
I think it's just dying to know how to
come out just to be useful I think
that's our fundamental Drive is to be
validated not selfish to be useful and
to make your life matter and I think
that there is nothing more nutritious to
experience more inspirational is you
know to that I am and I can leave
something so I think the energy that we
have locked away is nothing is more
powerful and that's the abundance it's
not in the stuff and I think - so the
the release of that energy is beauty
because it's a energy of service and
creation and I think that that's we
don't know you know that was the most
beautiful thing mother nature ever
created and and where I feel like a lot
of people are like look to others as
victims now look at what you're when you
actually see that energy witnessed at
look at someone and what they are and
see yourself in them it's seeing that
energy I'm a lineman with with then you
become a team I think that energy is the
96th going back seeing that life and
people that's the beginning of team
human again and it's scraping away all
that stuff that we're taught in
education makes us and all these
physical damn differences skin color
whatever that makes me different or you
know your sex differences and race that
doesn't matter
that energy is what bonds us and I think
that's the most beautiful thing and if
we release that we we come back to unity
together and I think nothing is more
spectacular and can do the most profound
if anything ever created so we love
maximizing
dividual and collective potential and
we're very grateful to have had you on
the show oh it's such a pleasure oh
thank you thank you thank you oh I get a
hug no you leave her alone get away from
there away from there thank you thank
you I mean this has been such a pleasure
everyone thank you for tuning in if you
guys had a good time definitely go check
out girl approved on us right yeah I
mean yeah it's in the bio so check it
out we'll make sure it's getting there
also everybody definitely give us a
comment below let us know your thoughts
we'd love to hear what you think about
unlocking these new senses and
augmenting scientific method and human
experience maximizing individual and
collective potential and keeping that
delight you know that delight of a child
that delight of a girl the delight of a
boy and bring them forth into the world
with that delight continuous over time
great sense of pleasure and also join us
subscribe join us on patreon will
greatly need your help in supporting the
studio and increasing our reach and
impact to do join us with that and join
us in rebirthing the public intellectual
and in inspiring you to build the future
thank you Ron a producer and director
thanks Heidi thank you so much you too
thanks everyone for tuning in
much love
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]